good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast ha
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on friday
that's right oh my god it feels so
[ __ ] good to be a friday hope
everyone is enjoying the deliciousness
acknowledging the space that we're
currently in we are the furthest away
from monday we are ever going to be
it's really really exciting today's a
beautiful friday here in new york it's
just
it's beautiful thing to behold
chef's kiss it's a gorgeous day
it's also
launch day you guys my tour my tickets
are officially on sale by the time this
episode comes out that's 12 p.m eastern
time so make sure to check your time
zone jackie and i had a little time zone
issue yesterday time zones are just so
unnecessary but i digress not like other
girls tour tickets are officially on
sale if you go to girlsnowjob.com
tour not to be mistaken for girl with no
job dot com slash book
but that's still so different but that
site is still up if you haven't gotten
your book yet so different but this is
girlwithnojob.comtour all the tickets to
all the shows are officially out for
everyone to buy i cannot wait to see you
guys on the road i hope you know all my
other girls who are
not like other girls will find solace in
this show well i have a question for you
and i feel like a lot of people might be
afraid to ask it but if someone is like
other girls
can they come to your tour
such a good question um and the thing is
no no kidding
no of course because the thing about
girls who are not like other girls is
like we don't judge girls who are like
other girls we are just girls being
girls being girly girls if that makes
sense yeah no makes perfect sense i'm
glad that we cleared that up no me too
and you know um a lot of people had been
wondering that so it was probably like
my most asked question so i'm really
glad that you kind of had the balls to
bring it up you know i speak for the
people oh the voice of the people and
that's also not to say that if you're
not like other boys
you can't come like
this is a fluid show it's not just for
the girls and it's not just for the
girls who are not like other girls it's
for everyone
okay well i'm gonna
i'm gonna wrap my mind around that it's
a lot to take it's a lot to take in no i
fully understand that i'm not like other
girls
i can't what about
dogs who are not like other dogs
no i don't think it's a dog friendly
show you don't think no you should do
one menu that allows
dogs like an outdoor venue and everyone
just brings their dogs on a lawn that's
an amazing idea book it call your pocket
i'll have my people call theo's people
amazing you guys do today was here again
today he's sitting with me and it seems
as though you have a better outlook
about it yeah well somebody you know the
thing is it's like you never complain
like about being pregnant like your feet
hurt or anything so i literally forget
like if you don't break it up for like a
week i will fully forget i'm like you
want to go get drinks like i do not
remember
um and you like don't really show your
bum that much so like i don't know i was
just forgot yesterday and somebody left
a comment on their instagram was like
theo's probably like gravitating towards
he could feel the energy of little
camper in your belly i mean that's why
he's like coming to protect and if i had
remembered that you were pregnant
yesterday like i wouldn't have made such
a fuss about it like a brat
but i that's on you actually like for
just not reminding everyone that you're
pregnant like all the time i feel like
pregnant people always like oh my ankles
are swollen like you know second
trimester you like i literally forgot
you're pregnant okay and that's good
that you know i'm not annoying anyone
with it
i wish you would what's going on with
you
not too much you know belly's getting
big though it is getting very big but
it's like fun i definitely like feeling
um tings in there things are happening
so it's just you know a beautiful
journey any complaints
i mean always i'm just like bored as
hell yeah yeah i feel that 100 um but
also speaking of beautiful journeys
our new merch oh yes i'm wearing talking
about so claudia's wearing one of our
new designs this is a set it says toasty
on the front i'm just yeah take we're
taking your voice away you're just going
to be a model it has happens to me all
the time champagne glasses on the sleeve
show them the glasses claude
and it comes with matching shorts which
our model is also wearing she might have
to stand up she can't she's sweating and
she got into a position where her legs
like look skinny so she can't move okay
i love this set so much it's so cute for
fall like such fall vibes and then also
really exciting i'm wearing this old
thing because we are bringing back this
sweatshirt our sorority crew neck that
is probably our most popular item that
we've ever sold is coming back to the
store on tuesday i'm wearing the one
that i've had for three years so it's
worn so the colors are more vibrant in
the new one but yours can look like that
too if you wear it as much as we do no
like it's the best sweatshirt ever the
best sweatshirt ever i love it so much
i'm so excited that it's finally coming
back we've gotten so many requests for
it because you know we launched it
three years ago so we have so many new
peeps here who want to get in on the
sorority
so that's really exciting we have a few
other things that we will show you over
the course of the next few days i think
you mentioned other
things i did i misspoke and again you
caught me hours that's what i do here so
reminder set your calendars tuesday 10
a.m eastern time the collection the fall
collection is launching and it's gonna
be great stuff so set an alarm it's
sickening the warehouse down for sure it
is i'm worried about the warehouse
it's the warehouse getting sick i'm
worried about the warehouse i'm hoping
that the warehouse will pull through and
just in time for all the sickening
designs to hit your mailbox tuesday that
is you guys don't forget at
shopmorningtoast.com
i'm really excited about that feeling
good that we got that off our chest i
need to ask you about your night oh yeah
yeah okay because i saw on instagram you
were in a mad dash to go meet tyler
cameron okay so ben left the house at
six o'clock
he said i'm going to dinner with jack
and elliot like his friends he's like
you want to come i'm like no
so i'm like living peacefully you know i
order chinese food hanging out with theo
scrolling tick tock and i realized like
so much time as fast i'm like where the
[ __ ] has been he went to dinner like not
far from the apartment so i facetime him
oh actually what had happened was i was
scrolling through my dms like just to
like see what people were up to and
someone was like tell your husband to
tell tyler to come say hi to me so i'm
like what
is ben with some hoes like yeah so i
facetime him and i'm like where the [ __ ]
are you and he opens the camera and he's
at a club and they're playing blank
space in the background and he turns the
camera next to him and it's tyler
from the bachelor so i'm like from snl
tyler literally so i'm like
first of all where are you second of all
you're listening to taylor swift without
me third of all you're hanging out with
reality stars without me like three very
uncool things so he's like we just got
to bounce i was about to leave but like
it's fun do you want to come
do i want to come so i'm like oh my god
it's a thursday night my hair is like
done
sure
got ready in 11 minutes literally never
got ready so fast
chugged the spritz got in the uber
i got down there and honestly like i
should have stayed home like i was there
for like 30 minutes but like i got it
was good for the instagram story but
like
i was just like
basically tyler was doing a um like an
appearance there so it was like people
were like just clamoring on him and it
was like funny and cool to watch but um
i don't know i just like i like took a
bunch of shots and then i was like why
am i here like
oh my god that's not what i thought you
were gonna say when i saw your stories i
was like do we need to push back the
show but then you didn't say anything
and then i woke up this morning praying
you would text me saying like shows
being bumped no no basically like on a
normal night i would have just like gone
all out but someone was holding me back
like i have a busy day today like i'm
launching my tour like i can't be that
irresponsible you know so true i'm a
grown woman with responsibilities like
if it were any other thursday though
like my ass would have been out till 6
a.m got it but i participated i got the
content so how did ben find himself
there with tyler c so ben and tyler c
share like a best friend right and so i
guess like the best friend texted ben
like you want to come to bounds and i
was like yeah sure
cool yeah girl yeah no it was um
like a whimsical new york city evening
that's really fun but i was really
grateful to like be in bed at 11 o'clock
but i'm also glad to have gotten if i
just saw your instagram story i would
think it was a whimsical new york city
evening now now seeing you and getting
the tea in person i'm a fraud yeah yeah
and that's why you have to listen to the
podcast it's not just enough to follow
me on instagram because like i lie on my
instagram but i tell the truth on this
podcast 100 so yeah
it was fun but like i just wanted to be
home you know yeah and i just eaten like
so much chinese food and like i walked
into the house like a big belly full of
chicken and broccoli like it was not a
good way to go damn
well you tried you know you put yourself
out there and honestly i just wanted to
ask tyler how snl was did you yeah of
course he was like it was amazing i'm
like you were so good he was
and then he was like yeah i was like
unreal i'm like you're so hot
did he ask about theo no like that's
actually why i left the disrespect so i
asked him so many questions about his
life his career his personal
not one question about my son so i had
to and they have a special bond not only
my son like his mistress 100 he didn't
even ask that's rude which i thought was
particularly disgusting
okay well thank you for that update any
other fun weekend plans no i actually
have like no plans because like i was
kind of exhausted coming back from my
vacation i'm like this weekend i'm just
going to relax but now it's the weekend
like i kind of want to do something i
was going to text like our group gbo
chat like not gvo that's from potomac
gno i was gonna text our gno chat like
if anyone wants like daydream tomorrow
because like i just kind of want to but
like i really need to like calm down
yeah that's true but you should have do
you want to take drinks
no but maybe like some bagels
that's a good idea you want to come over
for bagels does anyone have any outdoor
space in their apartment like it's
gorgeous out this is like the best time
of year yeah maybe text a chat does
anyone that we know have outdoor space
there's only one way to find out yeah i
will if they listen to the podcast reach
out yeah
okay well
without further ado i think we can jump
right in we have some great stories to
talk about we don't oh i mean it's like
a crazy [ __ ] day
what are you talking about okay so adele
first yeah yeah i heard i didn't want to
look into it because i knew i would
listen i heard that red taylor's version
was liked yes but then i heard it was
taken down oh was it yeah but then like
taylor released something on apple music
today not a song but like a voice note
to us so it was all just very confusing
like i woke up in a panic okay um and
then my tour like it's also national
news so it's just like a sensory yeah i
know part of the reason why like i was
hesitant to name
the tour not like other girls because
dirty jeans tour was amazing that was
also the djt
the end log like it's not sexy at all we
have to come up with a better way of
saying it yeah i like n log i think
there's a lot of potential there um and
laggy vibes and and wait enlagio yeah
i'm here for it okay okay so without
further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
today's episode is brought to you by the
peacock original show one of us is lying
five students walk into detention and
only four walk out alive follow the
story based on the number one new york
times bestseller one of us is lying now
an original peacock show on the first
day of school yale set bronwyn baseball
star cooper cheerleader addie and drug
dealing nate all land themselves in
detention and notorious gossip blogger
simon when one of them doesn't make it
out alive everyone becomes a suspect
each with their own secrets and motives
the juicy teen drama takes unexpected
new twists as we find out who's hiding
what in this can't miss new series with
romance betrayal secrecy and more one of
us is lying is the murder mystery of the
season so don't miss out on one of us is
lying streaming now only on peacock go
to
peacocktv.com to get started thank you
claudia peacock's not playing around
these days no they're not that show
looks so good yeah
okay
first story
it's adele day happy easy on me day and
also page six is reporting exclusively
that adele is plotting a massive tv
concert special for the holidays oh my
god for the holidays
that's gorgeous the grammy winner who
released her first new song in six years
this week which we will discuss
momentarily and has an album coming out
next month is plotting a concert special
that will air on tv by the end of the
year page six can confirm it's going to
be massive a source tease the show has
been in the works for weeks and the
details are being fined too now it will
be broadcast before the holidays both in
the us and the uk possibly beyond so i
had heard aka read on jumois that she
actually filmed something at buckingham
palace
yeah that's why it's like such a big
deal that's what i heard i don't know if
they said adele but they're like this
major uk and this is what it sounds like
like somebody filmed something at becky
buckingham palace and who else would it
be
oh my god that would be
a dream come true i know for me i know i
wonder if queenie was there foreign
she's definitely a fan queenie was
quaking in her kitten heels she's
probably like adele's number one fan
because not only is adele's music for
everyone but she represents she
represents the nation so well wow i hope
that's all true me too uh unconfirmed
but
i don't know i feel like it's definitely
true like what they're describing is
exactly what i feel like i read on like
a month ago yeah wow oh my god this even
better than i could have anticipated now
let's talk about the new song yeah and
the video okay so i first of all the
video was gorgeous like when that one
scene where it goes into color like i
had full body chills first of all second
of all if you look at the music video
for easy on me hello from the other side
and chasing pavements it's kind of like
a linear story in the chasing pavements
she's building a house
in hello it's me she's moving into the
house
now she's moving out of the house yeah
so i loved the meaning i thought the
lyrics were it was very clear what she
was singing about like this really is
this like love letter to her son
she did everything she could to save her
marriage this song is just
it's just gorgeous like there's
literally no other word for it no it's
gorgeous it's
quintessential adele so there's no like
having to adjust to a new sound while
also it's not boring or hurt or done
before it's like she killed it she
literally murdered it like she [ __ ]
slaughtered it and that's really what
you hope for from your
favorite artist's new album in six years
that it's more of the same but different
but more evolved elevated and it was
it's so good the song is so good it's
making me so excited for the album and
the video was stunning and you know what
like adele was like in this category of
people who were like we were all like
waiting for music for for like 10 years
like rihanna six years six years well
rihanna's been like nine years like
they're just like when are we ever
getting music from these people and to
be honest when there's that much hype
and like expectations it's more likely
than not that you're gonna fail like not
everyone's gonna like the sound i
haven't heard one bet and if somebody
comes to me with one [ __ ] bad thing
about this song like i'll kill you like
no there's nothing bad to say nothing
it's really beautiful it's
it's amazing she looks so good in the
music video like but so adelic she
obviously looks different she's had you
know a huge transformation but she's so
like herself i feel like she's really
the same person like her nails and her
facial movements like she's so adele and
i just [ __ ] love her and her
moves while she sings she's not dance
moves but like hand gestures yeah
and like the lip things like
you know yeah yeah she's everything she
really is everything this is a very
exciting chapter and i'm i'm glad to be
in this you know phase
and i'm glad to be living in like the
same time as adele like we could have
been born any time and like we were born
in the same time i think we're like
almost the same age as adele is she 30
is that just the name of the album no
she like this is what she experienced at
30 she might even be older older than
that she's younger than i thought
she has this like mature
vibe to her she's 33 now so she
obviously went through this at the age
30. three years ago technically i would
say mathematics
yeah for sure yeah i'm not sure i'll
have to check i do some quick math
you know i'm just gonna like
everyone on tick tock is gonna be like
doing their runs like well you know what
i was thinking
oh yeah like the people on today who are
influencers who also have a decent voice
and think that like you know that's
i feel like you're talking like directly
no i'm actually not i'm talking to you
i'm talking to james charles yeah
there's a lot of you guys
um
but i was thinking in the age of like
tick tock where like everything is
really done especially new music it's
like done with that in mind like what's
going to be the challenge how am i going
to get on the platform it's like this is
just so like back to basically it's like
it's just a good [ __ ] song and i
wonder i mean i don't i don't think
it's going to be on tick tock it's the
easy on me challenge no there might not
be a challenge but people just might use
it like see you're not really like up to
date on tick tock trends but so not
everything is like a challenge or a
dance now it's like you know show you at
your happiest and your status like a
song about adele could be like this was
me at my lowest but no like i could just
see people interpreting it that way okay
but also similar to what you were saying
when i was watching this video i was
really so moved by just like all of it
like the landscape the floating music
like
and we're just kind of used to sensory
overload in music videos like crazy
lights dancers everything like a twist
at the end like it was for me it was
just as good as any like crazy music
video but it had none of that like it
was really just simple and just stunning
yeah
i agree with all of those things but i
look forward to the easy on me challenge
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that is so funny
we should make it up
we should make up the easy the easy on
me challenge
are you ready for our next story
madison lacroix is engaged to her
boyfriend brett after seven months of
dating madison lacroix announced her
engagement to boyfriend brett on
thursday she said i'm engaged and i'm so
excited because i honestly had no clue
at the time she exclaimed on amazon live
on thursday it was a very special moment
for my family we traveled a good bit
around the world and i kind of thought
it would possibly happen then but i
think it happens when you least expect
it so it was an amazon live exclusive
announcement
you know she is like my messy queen i
just love her like she gives no [ __ ]
[ __ ] about anything she just like lives
her life and i just love it like after
all like that had happened over the last
like year and a half like yes girl get
engaged live your life no when it's like
last we saw her on tv
she was you know in the fall out of the
breakout from austin and now next time
we see her she'll be engaged woman and
between then she will have like broken
up one of the most famous like
engagements in our country's history jlo
and a-rod oh my god yes so she's just
like done like what are you i forgot
about that plus like jay cutler kristen
cavallari yeah you saw jay cutler is
allegedly dating jenna kramer i did see
that
and i i was a big jay cutler fan
no i actually don't know anything about
jenna kramer except that she like used
to fight with her husband on her podcast
but you know what as someone who's been
accused of fighting with my husband
maybe i don't know johnny kramer at all
maybe you have more in common than you
think 100
maybe it's like jay's dating you himself
maybe that's what basically was trying
to do 100
i think that's a weird couple i'm not
gonna lie just feels like he's literally
dating like another christian like
you think yeah
yeah it doesn't it's not like my
favorite i'm not sure
no no no not even like a canoe
okay
um anyways back to madison very happy
for her i mean they've seemed like a
happy couple but they've been together
seven months so that's you know
quick but when you know you know it's
quick for sure
but you know when you know you know yeah
so i leave for them i hope he'll be on
the show and we can you know assess the
situation yes amazon live with the uh
exclusive i haven't heard that before
yeah
was it like their
they do like that shopping thing yeah i
think like it was um but it wasn't
shopping it was like an interview or
like a live stream you know interesting
yeah i know that paige just sorbo does
it but she does like fashion yeah and
brad grusky does it too i think that she
did like she went live on amazon live
they paid her to share this special news
exclusively get your coin yeah what's
the point in getting engaged if you
can't exploit it on social media
i don't know okay this next story is um
really some crazy behind the scenes
degrassi news oh i heard about it is it
the crazy behind the scenes degrassi
news that's brought to you by
pendulum it is
what a crazy coincidence coincidence all
right you guys now we're all learning
about the connection between your gut
microbiome health and type 2 diabetes
well the pendulum glucose control is the
first and only probiotic that's designed
to manage a1c and blood glucose levels
through the health of your microbiome
over time people with type 2 diabetes
lose the gut bacteria that
help digest fiber and manage our blood
glucose levels so for those with type 2
diabetes diet and exercise alone are not
are often not enough to manage it the
best approach is to emphasize diet
exercise and a healthy gut this
connection has been has been widely
recognized by leading scientists and if
you're wondering why pendulum for those
with type 2 diabetes it can feel like an
uphill battle to keep glucose and a1c
levels where you need them diet and
exercise are still important but if you
struggle to manage your levels with diet
and exercise alone your gut microbiome
might need your attention pendulum
glucose control helps fill in the gaps
by providing the first and only
probiotic designed to manage blood
glucose and a1c levels their team of
scientists doctors and innovators
isolated the unique strains of
beneficial gut bacteria that help people
with type 2 diabetes manage their blood
sugar levels take control of your
glucose levels today try pendulum
glucose control for 90 days if you're
not satisfied with your levels you'll
get your money back visit
pendulumlife.com to find out more and
use the promo code tmt for 20 off your
first bottle of membership
that's pendulum life
p-e-n-d-u-l-u-m-l-i-f-e
dot com promo code t-m-c
thank you so much
it's a pleasure
okay here's the crazy behind-the-scenes
degrassi news drake threatened legal
action to get his degrassi character out
of the wheelchair the show's writer says
although
drake's star-making role in degrassi the
next generation remains beloved by many
according to the show's writer he
threatened legal action over his
character the four-time grammy award
winner starred in the first seven
seasons of the rebooted canadian teen
drama is jimmy brooks who was paralyzed
after being shot in a school shooting in
the season four two part episode time
stand still it was a very dark episode i
feel like we once that episode aired we
like weren't allowed to watch a show
anymore really no but we always saw
drake on the show oh yeah but at one
point we were we like we're told we
weren't allowed to watch it but i don't
think it was that like there was just a
lot going on it was like a crazy [ __ ]
show yeah so a former writer on the show
writer on the show recently recalled a
subsequent conversation he had with
drake about the character in an oral
history of the show published on
thursday by the av club he said there
was a letter from a law firm in toronto
and it was from aubry it was an odd
letter that said aubry graham will not
return to degrassi season six as jimmy
brooks unless his injury is healed and
he's out of the wheelchair that's like
not how it works i said get him down
here the writer recounted he came in and
was like what letter i don't know about
that and i said all right i understand
but how do you feel about the wheelchair
and drake said all my friends in the rap
game say i'm soft because i'm in a
wheelchair and i said well you could
tell your friends in the rap game that
you got shot how much harder can you get
you got shot and you're in a wheelchair
it's true he was like yeah yeah he was
so nice and apologetic about everything
he instantly backed down i feel i was
very passionate about it and i said
aubrey there's some kid somewhere in a
wheelchair who's completely ignored
who's never on television never gets
represented i need you to represent this
person you're the coolest kid on the
show and you can say there's nothing
wrong with being in a wheelchair oh wow
that's so huge a rep for drake did not
respond to people's obviously it's like
mortifying but also like jake drake was
like 16 like let's like no that but also
it is so crazy that drake is like the
biggest rapper in the world and he was
on degrassi no there's like a few things
like that like i think that way honestly
about ariana grande like that show sam
and cat like the moronic [ __ ] she used
to do like on victorious like totally
weird
yeah but to me that fee like
i see that more like
that makes a little bit more sense
not to me
it's [ __ ] weird no but there is a lot
of stuff like that yeah like people and
that's just how show business works like
you just get what you take what you can
get until you get where you need to be
yeah and like him 100 like him being on
degrassi is one of the weirdest things
of all [ __ ] time and this story like
100 tracks for me like he's trying to
make it in the rap game but he's on this
like tv show where he's like in a
wheelchair he's trying to be like doug
like i can see drake at 16 like being
upset about his circumstances yeah me me
too an interesting factoid about
degrassi
very interesting and just a reminder
that drake was on the grassy it just it
it never ceases to shock me when i think
about like where he is now yeah no you
know what everyone no matter who you are
has humble beginnings mm-hmm even that's
how also i feel about like meghan markle
like deal or no deal that's perfect
90210 speaking of 902.00 grimes is also
um from
yeah so many familiar faces not really
actually not enough considering it was a
very large cast and it was a huge show
but it was like deeply canadian
yeah but no it it resonated everywhere
but we used to watch it on the channel
the end is that what it's called the end
it was one of like nickelodeon's like
teen like teen drama you know it was
like the more racy channel like yeah
[ __ ] went down on the end
um that's also the end is where they
exclusively played that commercial
working for an hourly wage i went to
high school didn't do great still i
gotta make more cash more education is
what i'm looking at when i get a degree
i will make a bigger salary so now i've
got to see which colleges are right for
me i went on the internet and found
education connection i took some
pre-tests to find out my direction i'm
taking my classes online getting my
degree on my own time education
connection match me with the right
college for free get connected for free
with education connection get connected
for free for free with education
connection that's where my love of
education is where that commercial is
played 100
like on repeat
and like maybe kids who watch degrassi
needed education connection maybe they
did maybe drake should remix that song
bring it full circle no you know what
drake's song she should really mix the
theme song whatever it takes i know i
could make it through that would be sick
yeah and then they had like some people
from the show like come on and do a
verse like we got shanae grimes i'm sure
that like you know when things like this
come into the news like it really annoys
him
to have to go back there he's someone
and maybe you take umbrage with him but
he's someone who really you know turns
his back on the thing that made him
famous okay so that that's different
it's different that is the thing i hate
the most like
when like if like if miley hates hannah
montana that's like the best example um
but for real like i don't feel like i
knew who drake was like until he became
an artist not like a actor yeah no he
transformed from
being on degrassi like that's not the
that many different people it made him
like famous sure but like that's not why
he's drake no not at all but like you
know it's it's different
you know what it's not like someone who
had one big thing and now it's like
trying to do other stuff right
and they just like are trying to talk
about their small indie project when
it's like yeah let's talk about the
things
let's talk about the thing yeah yeah
okay ready for our next story yeah
addison ray jokes it's time to get a job
after her tick tock it's temporarily
banned this is really funny on thursday
the social media star shared a screen
grab on twitter of a notice she received
revealing that her tick-tock account had
been banned um it says your account was
permanently banned due to multiple
violations multiple violations of our
community guidelines permanently banned
this is permanent but then i checked
this morning and it was back like right
so why do they just throw around the
word permanent tiktok has the weirdest
thing like they take people's videos
down all the time like for community
guidelines violations where it's like
obviously there's like no nudity no
profanity you know hate speech and like
literally you'll be you'll put up a
video of like you making eggs this is
hate speech like they have the most
moronic
way of like enforcing their guidelines
so
like if you say the word like bra like
sometimes it's so weird so you'll get
violations all the time then you just
re-upload it and it's fine but if you do
hit a certain amount of violations like
even if you're addison right like they
have this automatic takedown of your
account and obviously addison ray got
her account back but like there are
plenty of people who like literally get
their tick tocks hanging down all the
time their accounts for no reason that's
so crazy do you think it's because it's
like an algorithm that is yeah it's not
human no it's a monitor it's not
monitored at all yeah so the bots get it
wrong yeah like literally sometimes my
videos won't go through and like this
violates our guidelines and it's
literally like a video of theo like it's
nothing crazy well maybe they have a a a
measure of how much cuteness you can
include in one video for sure or
sexiness provoking you know yeah content
and he was off the charts that's very
possible so that makes sense but anyways
it's like benign content madison then
joked well time to get a job which is
hysterical yeah but you know what's so
crazy like addison's so big like
honestly for tick tock let's say they
never gave her a ticket she would be
completely fine no she would be
completely fine she has multiple jobs um
she's not worried she's huge on so many
platforms like obviously she's biggest
on tick tock but she would survive she's
so big to me and i don't even have tick
tock right you know yeah that's true
she's an actress she has an instagram
she's music she's she's a celebrity now
she's a celebrity she should host snl
even though i'm sure no one would stand
for that there would be a walk out you
know there would be riots in the streets
that's such a good [ __ ] idea it
really is certain well she's 21 now yeah
but do you have to be a certain age to
who says no
i guess not i think of it like as
bartending on watch travis live like
um
i don't know there's no alcohol yeah
youngest snl host i feel like
quevengenie wallace has done it drew
barrymore at seven years old became the
youngest person ever to host us now
okay that's like a little chia yeah
that's what barrymore says all the time
like when she was a kid she was exposed
to like the craziest thing she like
started drinking when she was 12. okay
britney hosted at 18. oh so
addison could do it miley hosted at 18.
wow this is so interesting mary kate and
actually hosted at 17. i'm sure that was
amazing yeah two hosts taylor lautner
hosted at 17.
lindsay lohan 17. okay anyways plenty of
people so um addison by the way should
100 do it that's an amazing call yeah
but no but people would like you like
snl fans who like watch and dvr every
week like would die yeah no people had a
problem with kim and she's the most
famous woman on the planet
they would lose
their [ __ ] if addison hosted but you
know what like
i think back in the day like when
lindsay lohan hosted is that like
similar to addison wright hosting
no like teeny boppers that everyone
loves like i think it's just different
because tick-tock tick-tock yeah she
should [ __ ] do it and they could have
like bow and yang would write the best
[ __ ] sketches about like tick-tock
and addison right she would be amazing
they should do it and she could also be
the musical performer
okay that might be like a little bit
overkill singing says she only has one
song
um
but still
think about it free idea for you
more people in the industry should watch
this show we are constantly putting out
amazing ideas the facebook halftime show
genius genius the paul brothers fighting
each other no one's thought of that yet
i think they have actually
i don't think that was already that's
the point what that's the point
like when i said it i thought it was
like a new idea it's free it turns out
like they are always talking they're on
it yeah um
are you ready for the fifth and final
story
no
my breast is itchy i have a sunburn like
and it looks like i'm like edging my
boobs but it's just my upper chest wow
you really weren't ready right no i
didn't know no not yet hold on let me
fix my hair
okay how what decibel are we going at
cause i see a lot of people being like
jackie stop reading podcast reviews like
we've
made so many
adjustments for like four people so i
think we just [ __ ] do it i think we
let it rip it it's friday
and you know what i'm gonna order lunch
morning we're giving you three seconds
to lower your volume in case you have a
sleeping baby in the room
three
two
one it's the final story
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever it takes i know i can make it
through
whatever it takes i know i can make it
through
okay that felt so good i feel like i've
been just like hiding my true self these
past few days it feels so good to just
like come out of my shell yeah
okay fifth and final story jonah hill
says wait sorry
is it shown a hill story
about piravida
yeah
what
that is crazy
today's episode and the jonah hill news
is brought to you by ruthie and pura
vita shop now and give back with
piravita the coolest apparel and
accessories brands out there that are
always giving back it's always been at
the core of what they do
pura vita was started by two california
surfers who went to costa rica and fell
in love with the art and the laid-back
lifestyle now they're known for their
beautiful braided bracelets that are
handmade by artisans they've string
bracelets that are unisex fully
adjustable and wax coated so they're 100
waterproof all their jewelry is super
affordable so if you're looking for like
layered items cool rings um that are not
going to break the bank pura vida
has rings that just start at six dollars
um and bracelets
people love to buy them for stacking if
you're into like that cool tick tock
which who isn't pura vita is where it's
at again the bracelets start at six
dollars and the rings start at 12 and
you get free stickers with every order
but it's also clothing with a cause you
can shop their charity collections where
five percent of your purchase price is
given back to charities that support all
kinds of things from mental health to
ocean and land conservation pure vita
look good and do good and to get twenty
percent off your pure v to order text
toast to three eight eight one seven
that's toast to three eight eight one
seven to get 20 off at pura vida terms
apply available at
purevideobracelets.comterms
again that's toast to 38817 if you're
looking for sickening jewelry and
apparel i have so many of their rings
it's just great to like look like you're
always going to coachella
okay now for the fifth and final story
jonatha does not want fans to comment on
his body
period the wolf of wall street actor is
known for sharing fun and light-hearted
content on social media however he
switched things up yesterday when he
shared a message to remind his fans that
words have power he said i know you mean
well but i kindly ask that you not
comment on my body good or bad i want to
politely let you know it is not helpful
and does not feel good much respect okay
i 100 agree with everything he's saying
but like can i tell you what's so
[ __ ] annoying about this like
everyone's writing this up like oh make
like it's revolutionary like we women
have been saying this three years like
don't ask us if we're pregnant don't
like ask us if we lost weight like [ __ ]
off but like when jonah hill does it
it's like
oh my god like we know we've been asking
for this like for years like thanks
jonah but like we got this that's a good
point but but i agree like he has had
you know
he's looked different over the years and
people are always saying stuff about it
and like in good and positive ways it's
just annoying like if i want to gain
weight i want to gain weight if i want
to lose weight like i don't need to talk
about it you know yeah i think for him
it's definitely been so much a big part
of his even career
that
whether it's good or bad he just doesn't
want to hear it he just wants to live
his life yeah um
but you know you can always pay me a
compliment
that's how i feel totally you know um
also i just hope that ruthie could be
with him during this time to like kind
of work through some of those issues
everything i see
it just
it's so glaring how much he needs ruthie
in his life and you know what every time
we report something about jonah hill
like in the last like couple years i'm
just like obsessed like i really don't
have one negative thing to say about you
don't forget he is in a relationship
right now so
it's easy to forget when you're so
focused on ruthie the ruthie-sized hole
is being filled currently no not not as
much as it could the rubies the hole
that ruthie left was so enormous no
person could fill it besides ruthie i
don't know the their announcement when
he like shared that he was dating
someone i just i really have faith in
this couple and i it's hard because like
i'm a rona stan
for sure i know i'm more of a juicy stan
but i i think he's in a really good
place i hope he's like in a good
relationship i hope so like only the
best for him and ruthie 2.0
um happy for them of course happy for
them jonah hill has like really the most
wonderful catalog of work i think like
maybe one of my favorites because he's
he did the oscar thing moneyball wolf of
wall street but he's also been like some
of the dumbest movies of all time like
super bad right he did that first yeah
no and it's like
i think they're equally as good both the
before the before oscars and after
oscar's content is just as good yeah i
agree it's a good catalog
oh accepted you ever see that movie of
course so good so good it's actually
like the one movie for some reason on my
computer that i've ever bought on itunes
and whenever i'm on a plane it's
literally the only thing i have to watch
it's actually a pleasure that's a pretty
good one to have yeah what's yours
actually for a while i also had the boy
in the stripe pajamas but i just decided
to delete it that's good i had to watch
it in college like for class and so i
just bought it and then it was always on
my computer and i'd be on a plane i'm
like what should i watch i don't have
any any movies on my computer i also
have the first episode of alan gregory
oh i guess on my itunes but i don't have
that stuff downloaded like i have like
random episodes of jersey shore and
stuff from when we like used to
watch stuff on like itunes also speaking
of jonah hill's unbelievable category
alan gregory's critically acclaimed
canceled after one
season
animated show alan gregory which is
literally i think like
so [ __ ] good he's like this
diva
kid who's like six years old his dads
are gay and they like hate him and it's
just like and he's like rich and he's
mean to all the kids at school it's so
good it's the prince before the prince
that's what i was thinking yeah he was
before his time yeah
so good for alan gregory justice for
alan gregory um well that's really all i
have to say today it's friday i'm ready
to get the weekend started if anybody
has an outdoor patio they want to let me
use because i'm trying to throw a party
tomorrow let me know yeah and get your
tickets to the end log tour oh thank you
end log not like other girls tickets are
officially on sale at girlwithnojob.com
heading up all the towns austin houston
texas wait
austin houston dallas common texas
minneapolis detroit
where
that's gonna be the best one by the way
sorry parks casino close to philly that
is my favorite place on planet earth me
and brian go like every weekend bride's
obviously coming i'm actually thinking
of like having brian do a set like
that's like his home i'm thinking of him
like having
like having him come up on stage and
like do 10 minutes would he want to do
that for sure you should do it or like
have him be like a part of the show in
some way like dj or something yeah and
what happened to turning stone now
so
that hurt the thing i got a lot of
questions about like why i chose certain
cities and like why so few shows and so
basically over the last tour i ended up
doing 90 shows because like i didn't
know i was a first-time comedian i don't
know if people were gonna like even come
so i would do like a small comedy club
and then i was able to do like 10 shows
at one comedy club so just for my own
like mental and physical health it's
easier for me to do one show at a major
theater as opposed to like 20 shows at
surrounding comedy uh clubs then you
know i was just testing out new markets
i'd never been on tour before so i was
doing things like turning stone and
while tourney stone was really fun it
only sold about 70 of the tickets so
like i didn't i don't need to go so not
all stones were turned no not at all
that's why we were by the way that's why
we were literally promoting it so hard
on my jackie like i have like two shows
out of like my remaining ones that like
are not selling like we have to like be
annoying about it so that's why we were
turning them stones oh my god but we had
so much fun yeah who knew i know that's
what happens out of
the challenge mother of invention 100
so that's why i chose to do fewer shows
bigger venues amazing so if you have to
travel about 30 minutes i'm sorry but i
would still absolutely love to see you
we're gonna have the best time and it's
just gonna be a girly girl affair
all the cameras coming out a girly girl
affair oh yeah all right
i love that song justice for jessica
simpson's entire catalog of music 100
um she served it up for herself though
with her book she didn't look like and
now her series coming out on amazon she
gave herself that's what ruthie needs to
do
give herself over to the music yes she
needs to write a book a hundred percent
my time my week with marilyn my week
with jonah my message with joan oh yeah
she never even met him they just
messaged okay my dms with jonah
um all right you guys that is our show
hope everyone has an amazing weekend
stay safe and if you are looking for
something to do there's tons of content
on our patreon channel you could read my
book you could listen to the redheads
you could listen to any of the tnn shows
we had so much content for you guys it's
amazing that we ever sleep have a great
day we'll see you on monday thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the monday morning show where we deliver
the past live stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and we're a
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i have
video cast blocks all the places so
whenever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast sleep before i start
you about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and if you still need to end
this episode congratulations you are a
true toaster who really believes in the
power of the toast and you are part of
the society season two so to let us know
that you are true toaster who makes it
to the end of the episode head over to
our most recent instagram from today and
drop an emoji one emoji should it be jax
your call today that's such a good
question it's like the hardest thing i
know what did we talk about let me go
back to my story we talked about adele
we talked about drake
we talked about madison lacroix we
talked about addison
it's really hard okay i'm just gonna go
random yeah
apple
okay i like an apple apple everyone have
a great day that was my choice today but
okay yeah you took too long um because
there's so much content at the end of
that i know then people okay goodbye bye